realicemos más ejemplos para cuando
buscamos límites de funciones cuando de
que se aproxima a infinito oa menos
infinito así que aquí tenemos esta loca
función 9 x a la séptima menos 17 x a la
sexta más 15 por la raíz de x sobre 3 x
a la séptima más 1000 por x ahora quinta
menos logaritmo base 2 de x y entonces
qué pasaría si x se aproxima a infinito
y la llave aquí es como lo vimos en
otros ejemplos es simplemente ver qué
términos dominan en dicha función en la
parte de arriba en el numerador por
ejemplo de todos estos tres términos el
que domina es 9 x a la séptima va a
crecer mucho más rápido que todos estos
términos por lo que es el que domina en
esta parte y en la parte del denominador
de estos tres el que domina obviamente
es el 3 x a la séptima incluso que la
parte que dice más mil x a la quinta y
que el menos logaritmo de base 2 por
supuesto de x entonces vamos a dejar
estos dos términos que están dominando
este cociente así que conforme x se
aproxima cada vez más a infinito nos va
casi casi igual a este cociente de aquí
entonces podemos igualar el límite de
cuando x se aproxima a infinito a este
cociente y también conforme se aproxima
a infinito éstos se van acercando uno
con el otro por lo que podemos cancelar
dicho término y simplemente realizar el
cociente lo cual finalmente nos queda
que dicho límite va a ser igual a 3
después de tener toda esta loca función
podemos igualarlo a este límite y ahora
pasando a la segunda función que tenemos
por aquí de igual forma es una función
bastante loca y al aproximarnos a menos
infinito veamos que resulta entonces es
la misma idea que términos dominan dicha
función en la parte del numerador sería
en cuanto a 3x al cubo y en alde el
denominador sería con 6x a la cuarta
entonces lo escribimos por acá dicho
cociente al cual nos estamos aproximando
cuando x se aproxima a menos infinito y
luego entonces también podemos realizar
dicho cociente entre estos dos términos
lo cual nos podrá quedar uno en la parte
de arriba porque se cancela la equis con
la de abajo y en la parte superior en la
parte inferior 2
y bueno qué pasa con esto cuando x en el
denominador incluso toma valores
realmente grandes hablando negativamente
esto se convierte en uno sobre un número
realmente grande en términos negativos
lo que esto nos va a llevar a estar muy
próximos de alcanzar un valor igual a
cero entonces el límite de cuando x se
aproxima menos infinito de 1 sobre 2x se
queda casi cerca del cero por lo que lo
vamos a igualar donde si quisieras
realizar las gráficas para comprobar qué
pasa con esta función podría darte
cuenta de que hay una cinta
horizontal para cuando hoy es igual a 0
y la llave maestra de todo esto es
observar qué números dominan al resto y
simplemente nos ayuda a crear el
problema más fácil y en este último
ejemplo que tenemos por aquí vamos a
igualarlo a los términos dominantes
entonces tenemos que conforme el límite
se aproxima a infinito se acerca a este
cociente de 4x a la cuarta sobre 250 x a
la cúbica y al cancelar el término de
puesto que la potencia de arriba es
mayor tenemos que esto es igual al
límite de cuando el que se aproxima a
infinito de 4 sobre 250 x x dado que la
potencia de arriba fue mayor lo cual
también podemos igualarlo a lo siguiente
igualarlo al coeficiente de 4 sobre 250
y todo esto multiplicado por el límite
de cuando x se aproxima a infinito de x
y bueno al hacer este límite del límite
cuando x se aproxima a infinito de x es
simplemente infinito se está acercando a
un número muy muy grande y está
multiplicando a un coeficiente que en
realidad no le va a afectar casi para
nada a un número que está demasiado
grande entonces esto tiende a irse a
infinito aquí la observación será la
siguiente que cuando tengas una función
que en la parte de el numerador que
estoy encerrando aquí sea mayor que la
parte del denominador que domine
prácticamente a toda esta función la
potencia de el numerador dicha función
casi siempre se va a comportar de esta
forma que ésta va a tender
siempre hay infinito dado que el número
de arriba es mayor y al contrario cuando
tenemos una potencia que domina en el
denominador esta función entenderá
acercarse o aproximarse demasiado hacia
cero y así siempre